bonsoir bienvenue ravie de vous
retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce soir
un grand historien grand spécialiste de
la Seconde Guerre mondiale bonsoir
Olivier Lorca et merci d'être notre
grand témoin vous publiez une histoire
totale de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
chez Perrin c'est une synthèse
magistrale passionnante et accessible à
tous qui couvrent absolument tous les
fronts militaires économiques sociales
idéologique politique et même raciale on
va en parler longuement et qui balaye au
passage quelques mythes qui ont la dent
dure dans notre mémoire collective on en
parle ensemble dans la deuxième partie
notre grand débat ce soir la réforme du
référendum c'est une annonce surprise
d'Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui à
l'occasion des 65 ans de notre
Constitution le chef de l'État qui veut
ouvrir le champ d'application du
référendum et simplifié la procédure
d'initiative citoyenne la souveraineté
populaire pour répondre à la défiance
démocratique on en parle dans un instant
avec mes invités sur ce plateau enfin
nos affranchis ce soir le billet philo
de Pierre-Henri tavoyau l'œil sur le
numérique de Delphine Sabatier et puis
Bourbon Express bien sûr l'histoire de
jour à l'Assemblée signée Stéphanie des
pierres voilà donc pour le programme on
y va les vieilles Orca ça vous regarde
c'est parti
[Musique]
on ne touche à la constitution que d'une
main tremblante la phrase de Monster
dans les mémoires mais à 65 ans notre
loi fondamentale n'a-t-elle pas besoin
d'être un peu modifié c'est en tous les
cas ce que propose le chef de l'État
Emmanuel Macron avec sa réforme du
référendum alors pour faire quoi comment
et dans quel but bonsoir Caroline a dit
bonsoir bienvenue sur ce plateau vous
êtes député renaissance de l'Isère vous
débattez ce soir avec deux de vos
collègues Antoine Léo Mans bonsoir
député la France insoumise de l'Essonne
bonsoir Philippe Gosselin député les
républicains de la Manche et évidemment
on a besoin d'un constitutionnalisme
bonsoir Benjamin Morel vous êtes maître
de conférence en droit public à la
Faculté d'Assas Olivier wiiorca votre
regard historien nous intéresse parce
que c'est un texte la Constitution mais
il y a aussi un contexte et des hommes
et des femmes derrière qui qui s'en
emparent bien évidemment vous réagissez
quand vous le souhaitez alors qu'est-ce
qu'il a dit le chef de l'État que
retenir de son discours devant les sages
de la rue de Montpensier c'est le chrono
de Blacko tout de suite qui va nous le
dire on accueille Stéphane blackovsk
bonsoir mon cher Stéphane je me retourne
pour vous accueillir je vous invite à
faire la même chose et tous alors
la Cinquième République alors je sais on
chante pas sur LCP mais là c'est
exceptionnel ce sont les 65 ans de la 5e
République on peut se le permettre alors
65 ans ça sera pas dans les deux
manières c'est un signe de longévité
presque un record pour une République
dans notre pays et en même temps 65 ans
on dépasse l'âge légal de la retraite
donc c'est peut-être le moment de
tourner la page vous savez que certains
sont partisans lors de la l'an dernier
lors de la campagne présidentielle
Jean-Luc Mélenchon avait répété que lui
il voulait oublier la cinquième et
passer à la Sixième République donc
autant vous dire que ce matin le
président n'était pas très emballé par
ce projet puisqu'il a carrément dit que
c'était à la fois
inutile et présomptueux donc j'imagine
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon réagira en
revanche plutôt qu'une nouvelle
République le président est prêt à
réviser la Constitution actuelle il faut
dire que elle a déjà été modifiée à 24
reprises depuis sa création donc
pourquoi pas un nouveau petit lifting
pour lui donner un coup de jeunesse donc
sur quel principe le mener bien il a
rappelé un grand principe le président
qui est celui inscrit dans l'article 3
de la Constitution la souveraineté
nationale appartient au peuple il exerce
par ses représentants qu'on s'amuse ce
soir puisque certains sont là mais aussi
par la voix du référendum et là c'est un
peu plus compliqué parce qu'en fait le
peuple français c'est pas si facile pour
lui d'exercer ça souveraineté par
référendum pourtant c'est pas l'envie
que tu lui manques regardez des sondages
voyez que 80% même plus des Français
voudrait qu'on organise plus de
référendum et si on leur dit un
référendum sur les retraites ou un sur
l'immigration et bien les trois cartes
d'entre eux seraient souhaiteraient
sur ce sujet d'ailleurs bien sûr que ça
a été entendu regardez à droite et bien
Éric Ciotti pendant sa rentrée dans le
sud ou bien Jordan Bardella lors des
rencontres de Saint-Denis tous les deux
réclament un référendum sur
l'immigration le problème c'est que
l'immigration vérifiera avec les
constitutionnalisme ne fait pas partie
des domaines sur lesquels il est prévu
qu'on puisse organiser des référendums
donc pour ça il faudrait modifier
l'article 11 de la Constitution qui est
celui qui explique comment et dans quel
cadre on peut organiser organiser un
référendum le président a l'air d'être
partant on l'écoute il existe encore des
domaines importants pour la vie de la
nation qui échappe au champ de l'article
11 de notre Constitution
j'ai ouvert ce chantier à Saint-Denis
avec l'ensemble des forces politiques et
je souhaite que nous puissions trouver
collectivement les moyens de mener à son
terme ce chantier mais puisqu'on parle
d'idées de référendum on pourrait aussi
parler de ce projet de référendum sur la
retraite que cette fois-ci vous voulez
organiser la gauche en l'occurrence un
référendum d'initiative populaire sauf
que là aussi il y a eu un obstacle vous
voyez c'est le Conseil constitutionnel
qui a rejeté à deux reprises cette
demande et combien même le Conseil
aurait accepté cette demande de
référendum d'initiative populaire il
aurait encore fallu réunir 4 millions
800 000 signatures ce qui est un bel
engagement de souveraineté populaire
mais non ça n'aurait pas suffi même ces
4 millions de signatures il aura fallu
en plus que le Parlement donne son
accord donc c'est un peu compliqué du
coup le président se dit qu'on pourrait
peut-être simplifier ces référendum
d'initiative populaire en écoute
la souveraineté populaire peut également
s'exprimer directement à l'issue d'un
référendum d'initiative partagée
cette procédure
utile est aujourd'hui excessivement
contrainte
sa mise en œuvre doit être plus simple
et les seuils permettant son usage comme
peut-être ces procédures devraient dès
leur être revues
je vais vous laisser débattre juste
histoire d'être à peu près complet on
sait qu'il est aussi parlé d'autres
révisions péchées de la Constitution
comme y inscrire le droit à l'IVG ou un
nouveau statut pour l'accord pour la
Nouvelle-Calédonie et même pourquoi pas
une grande réforme de la
décentralisation pour aller encore plus
loin mais ce soir la question c'est de
savoir d'une part est-ce qu'on doit
organiser plus souvent des référendum et
puis ce qu'on peut le faire sur tous les
sujets c'est à vous merci beaucoup
c'était parfaitement clair Caroline
Abadie on va essayer de comprendre ce
qui a voulu faire avec ce discours le
Chef de l'État on a l'impression d'un et
en même temps il ouvre la voie d'un
référendum sur un autre sujet qui n'est
pas dans la liste de l'article 11 de la
Constitution pourquoi pas l'immigration
réclamée par la droite et l'extrême
droite et il ouvre la voie simplifier ce
fameux référendum d'initiative partagée
donc décidé par des citoyens que réclame
depuis longtemps la gauche c'est comme
ça qu'il faut comprendre ce qu'il a fait
aujourd'hui
il y avait aujourd'hui clairement une
date symbolique nous passions les 65 ans
cette constitution et il a rappelé que
c'était une matière vivante qui avait
toujours évolué et qui n'a pas évolué
depuis longtemps c'est vrai qu'on a eu
peine à faire des référents des des
réformes constitutionnelles sur le
précédent mandat et je pense que dans le
mandat d'avant non plus il n'avait pas
eu donc je pense la dernière remonte à
2008 et qu'il faut bien la faire vivre
parce que c'est aussi ça qu'on entend
qu'on comprend l'aspiration de nos
citoyens
du premier sujet le référendum la
réforme du référendum sur son champ
d'application il n'a pas dit sur quoi
vous personnellement un référendum sur
l'immigration comme le réclame la droite
et Marine Le Pen vous y êtes favorable
je me suis pas encore fait vraiment
d'avis sur la question moi je sais qu'on
va de toute façon débattre de ce sujet
là avant qu'il réforme constitutionnelle
qui arrive sur sur le thème de
l'immigration ce que je peux dire c'est
que on a aujourd'hui une majorité
relative à l'Assemblée nationale qui
viennent majorité à droite au Sénat et
que il est assez logique d'écouter aussi
cette voix qui est forte qui vient de la
droite sur ces sujets là maintenant moi
je sais que on en aura débattu bien
avant que c'est une réforme constitue
vous êtes très prudente j'ai
l'impression Philippe Gosselin vous vous
le réclamez aux républicains ce
référendum sur l'immigration le
Président vous tend la main c'est comme
ça que vous l'avez compris bah écoutez
je sais pas si nous tend la main mais ça
fait effectivement quelques années qu'on
a des échecs de révision il y a eu 2018
en pleine affaire Barbara il y a eu
évidemment aussi en 2019 donc voilà il
faut peut-être remettre un peu le le
chantier en route alors oui nous on a
une demande effectivement de référence
consulter les Français sur quoi
l'immigration savoir si par exemple
c'est une de nos propositions on fixe
dans la Constitution et ça serait voté
annuellement ensuite un quota qui
permettrait de mieux accueillir de mieux
intégrer et de mieux et davantage
contrôler c'est une vraie question que
beaucoup de nos concitoyens se posent ça
dépasse en réalité largement le
positionnement du RL ou d'autres on le
voit bien 74% de nos compatriotes
souhaitent un référendum sur le sujet
jusqu'à preuve du contraire ils sont pas
tous chez Le Pen ou ailleurs donc il y a
des sujets effectivement que les
Français ont envie d'avoir en main après
il faut trouver l'équilibre entre la
souveraineté nationale c'est la voie du
Parlement des représentants et puis ne
pas tomber dans une utilisation qui
serait trop simple aux yeux de certains
trop faciles pour d'autres du référendum
faut trouver cet équilibre aujourd'hui
il y a plus de référendum et qu'il est
tendre donner la parole d'hypothèses et
puis juridiquement c'est compliqué on va
on va en parler avec Benjamin Morel mais
il met ton se référendum sur
l'immigration soit rendue possible à ce
moment-là vous votez le texte le projet
de loi c'est un donnant donnant qui est
il faut voir ce qu'il y a dedans vous
savez il y a des étapes pour pouvoir
modifier la Constitution faut l'accord
des deux chambres il faut une majorité
si on passe devant le Congrès des trois
cinquièmes donc ça ça on va y revenir
quand même pas mal de monde et juste
puisqu'on évoqué Caroline abatty Abadie
et évoqué la réforme de 2008 on avait
une grosse majorité à l'époque de
Sarkozy le Sénat avait une grosse
majorité et je rappelle que les 3/5
alors que la majorité était écrasante ne
s'est gagné qu'à deux voies près on va
revoir ça donne un peu les enjeux les
différents critères pour parvenir à la
révision constitue elle si c'est pour
consulter les Français sur l'immigration
chez les insoumis c'est non mais de
toute façon on peut consulter les
Français sur n'importe quoi et d'une
manière générale ce que montre les
sondages que vous montriez tout à
l'heure c'est que les Français veulent
avoir la parole sur à peu près
l'ensemble des sujets et avoir le
pouvoir de décider de de
qui de ce qu'on va faire de notre pays
nous vous le savez on propose de sortir
de cette cinquième république et quelque
part la formule tout à l'heure était
assez bonne à arriver à 65 ans il est
temps que la Cinquième République prenne
sa retraite en tout cas c'est ce que
nous pensons nous pourquoi parce que les
élections présidentielles justement ça
n'est pas du tout l'intention locale il
peut y avoir des situations
exceptionnelles dans lesquelles ma foi
on convoque une assemblée constituante
pour que le peuple puisse redéfinir ses
institutions et redéfinir quelles sont
les règles de vie commune qu'il se donne
je pense que par exemple le 49-3 est une
une un article de la Constitution qui
est très contradictoire avec l'histoire
de la France vous savez que le véto
royal dont on débattait qui est
d'ailleurs à l'origine de la gauche et
de la droite le véto Royal pouvait
porter sur tous les sujets c'est à dire
le roi pouvait empêcher une loi d'entrer
en application mais il y avait un sujet
sur lequel ça pouvait pas être utilisé
c'était le vote du budget bah maintenant
c'est l'inverse le 49-3 c'est pire que
le béton Royal alors pour revenir
l'utiliser spécifiquement sur le budget
juste sur le sens du discours élargir un
ouvert un nouveau pense à l'immigration
pas précisé c'est pas l'urgence pour
vous c'est clairement pas l'urgence non
il y a d'autres urgences notamment sur
la question du pouvoir d'achat mais
d'une manière générale nous nous sommes
favorables au fait que les citoyens
aient un pouvoir d'initiative sur tous
les sur le référendum surtout les sujets
et vous savez moi je suis plutôt amateur
de la constitution de la Première
République qui disait que un peuple ne
peut assujettir à ses lois les
générations futures et qu’un peuple a
toujours le droit de revoir réformer
échanger sa constitution moi les
générations passées ne peuvent pas
assujettir à leur loi les générations
futures et ma génération en tout cas
nous aspirons à pouvoir changer de
constitution à pouvoir redéfinir les
règles du ça c'est le programme
présidentiel des insoumis on renvoie aux
écrits de Jean-Luc Mélenchon mais on va
rester on va parler de l'initiative
citoyenne dans un instant mais Benjamin
Morel il faut essayer de comprendre
proposition présidentielle comment vous
vous la comprenez est-ce que il y a de
la tactique derrière est-ce que au
contraire c'est intéressant de se dire
il manquait à la liste de l'article 11
qui prévoit déjà les sujets d'autres
sujets alors déjà c'est un vieux débat
c'est un débat notamment qui émerge dans
les années 80 au moment de la loi Savary
à l'époque François Mitterrand ben
renvoie un peu la droite dans ses
vendeurs en disant mais vous la
référendum sur un service national de
l'éducation on y va sauf que à l'époque
l'article 11 de le permet pas ça va
arriver c'est à dire qu'en 1995 on a
déjà un élargissement de l'article 11 on
va ajouter la politique sociale
économique et environnementale de la
nation et les services publics mais en
revanche on veut pas de référendum sur
la peine de mort pas de droit pénal on
veut pas non plus qu'il puisse y avoir
des référendums sur la nationalité pas
de droit civils or aujourd'hui quand on
pense référendum sur l'immigration
l'immigration c'est pas en soi l'objet
d'un référendum qu'on introduirait dans
la Constitution en mettant immigration
en plus dans la Constitution en fait
c'est un sujet mais derrière il y a des
sujets pénaux il y a des sujets civils
et donc si on veut rédiger cet article
il faut la dessus être clair et ça
Emmanuel Macron n'a pas été triangle il
a posé deux lignes rouges
l'intangibilité du droit d'asile et
l'égalité des citoyens devant la loi ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'avec ces
deux lignes rouges un référendum sur
l'immigration n'est pas possible tout
dépend en réalité il en a posé une note
qui en fait l'État de droit et là il
faut bien voir que si on prend par
exemple le projet de LR si on prend le
projet du rassemblement national il y a
des sujets qui vont être des sujets de
droit européen et donc là vous ne
revenez pas sur des dispositions qui
peuvent être et disposition de droits
européens hors aujourd'hui c'est à dire
demander aux Français de sortir des
traités pour reprendre sa souveraineté
migratoire
à la Danoise il faut voir que on a 29
lois depuis 1980 sur l'immigration en
moyenne une toutes les trois ans le
problème en matière d'immigration n'est
pas d'abord la loi c'est d'abord la
hiérarchie des normes avec la question
évidemment du droit européen qu'on soit
pour ou contre et de l'autre côté
l'application de la loi donc si vous
rentrez pas je dirais dans un jeu qui va
être un jeu de remise en cause ou en
tout cas de réorientation de ces types
de choses et bien vous risquez de
décevoir parce que le référendum c'est
un très très bel outil ça permet au
peuple de s'exprimer mais infini ça rend
pas votre votre loi très différente la
loi votée par référ elle est toujours
soumise au droit européen la loi votée
par référendum vous pouvez toujours la
présenter au gouvernement d'Alger en
disant là il va falloir des laisser
passer très clair sur les autres lois
c'est la Constitution exactement et de
l'autre côté ça ne les rend pas plus
applicable c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
quand on a des soucis en matière
notamment de laisser passer consulaire
c'est pas parce que votre loi va être
votée par référendum qu'elle va être
plus effective c'est bien trop flou
alors un c'est flou il a dit juridique
c'est compliqué et ensuite je ne suis
pas sûr que la loi aujourd'hui soit
vraiment le véhicule idoine en matière
d'immigration bon et ben écoutez on va
continuer à en parler on va regarder
comment on réagit les principales
formations politiques à cette initiative
présidentielle de révision
constitutionnelle et au passage remettre
un peu les pendus d'ailleurs sur la
procédure à des semer d'embauche pour
parvenir à cette révision c'est un sujet
de Marion Becker regardez
depuis les rencontres de Saint-Denis
toutes les oppositions s'attendaient à
l'élargissement du champ référendaire
mais après les annonces d'Emmanuel
Macron elle reste méfiantes simplifiée
ça veut dire quoi qu'est-ce qu'il entend
par là à quel niveau si on ne
bouleverse pas transforme pas totalement
le rip on n'aura pas atteint l'objectif
de la même manière il explique déjà
qu'il y a une limite certains cadres il
explique par exemple que le référendum
ne serait revenir sur une loi adoptée à
l'Assemblée parce que par exemple sur la
loi retraite d'optée par le 43 ça serait
le cas oui bien qu'il y a des
limitations tout de suite qui sont
données encore une fois une victoire
idéologique du rassemblement national
qui réclame la facilité d'organiser des
référendum depuis je pense à peu près
une trentaine d'années bon il y a qu'un
malheur c'est que Emmanuel Macron il y a
quelques semaines de cela avait dit
qu'il acceptait tous les référendum sauf
sur l'immigration
donc vous voyez cette relativement
contradictoire mais il nous a habitué à
cette contradiction permanente mais pour
acter l'élargissement du champ des
référendums et l'assouplissement du
référendum d'initiative partagée le
Sénat et l'Assemblée devront se mettre
d'accord et adopter à la majorité le
projet de révision régi par l'article 89
après quoi Emmanuel Macron a deux
options soit il organise un référendum
pour le ratifier soit il convoque le
Congrès à Versailles qui pour l'adopter
doit recueillir 3 cinquième des
parlementaires
Benjamin Morel c'est quoi c'est un échec
assuré c'est pas gagné alors c'est en
effet pas du tout gagné quelques
comparaisons historiques on n'a jamais
eu de réformes globale de la
Constitution ça a été évoqué à moins
d'avoir une majorité concordante à
l'Assemblée au Sénat à l'époque Nicolas
Sarkozy toilette la moitié de la
Constitution mais c'est la première fois
qu'il a une majoritaire absolue à
l'Assemblée et au Sénat d'un même parti
aujourd'hui vous avez une majorité
différente dans les deux chambres ça
vous a pas échappé et en règle générale
on ne sait dans ces contextes là assurer
de s'accorder que sur quelques points
alors là il va en avoir plusieurs il va
y avoir référendum il va également y
avoir
IVG l'environnement la décentralisation
tout ça tous les sujets
IVG RIP dans un même dans une même loi
de révision au parlementaire
des accords de Nouméa pour des raisons
en fait des chances de ces accords donc
ça c'est de côté mais pour le reste on
devrait avoir comme un texte global
parce que vous voyez bien par exemple
que les textes IVG environnement
aujourd'hui sont bloqués de pas les
reprendre dans un texte global c'est en
fait soit les abandonner soit entre
guillemets et bien tous aussi sonner
donc ça paraît aujourd'hui relativement
compliqué donc jamais de révision jamais
de révision si jamais vous avez une
opposition globale si jamais vous avez
une opposition entre les deux chambres
par ailleurs vous a pas non plus
échapper qu'on avait une majorité
relative à l'Assemblée la dernière
configuration à la matière c'est 62
qu'est-ce qui se passe le gouvernement
Pompidou tombe de Gaulle dissous et il
utilise l'article 11 c'est-à-dire qu'il
bazarde le Parlement pour pouvoir
consulter directement les Français c'est
plus possible depuis des décisions du
Conseil consuel de 2005 la décision au
shy donc aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron
peut pas utiliser l'article 11 il a
besoin d'une majorité conforme et à ce
stade là je dirais que toutes les cartes
et l'histoire joue plutôt contre lui
c'est perdu d'avance c'est un peu ce qui
nous dit Benjamin vous comprenez vous
comprenez un petit peu il y a un beau
sujet c'est l'IVG inscrit dans la
Constitution là peut-être qu'il y a les
trois cinquième pourquoi pourquoi il
ouvre tous ses chancés ces fameux
rencontres de Saint-Denis ou il avait
promis d'ouvrir la voie référendaire au
parti d'opposition à la droite qu'est-ce
qui est le prochain rendez-vous c'est le
30 octobre qu'est-ce qui fait exactement
je comprends pas trop là on est on
veut montrer qu'on est pas sur un temps
mort l'IVG ça a pas encore un an et on
en parle presque plus donc c'est faut
relancer des sujets ils nous redemande
de nous remettre au travail si nous le
demande pas aujourd'hui effectivement ça
reste enterré dans une navette et
personne ne s'en saisit l'environnement
qu'on voulait inscrire dans la
Constitution lors en suivant la cette
convention citoyenne pour le climat
l'appareil on en reparle plus de depuis
21 il faut qu'on en reparle donc
pourquoi ça nous remet pas par exemple
une multiplication des des sujets
effectivement
IVG environnement il y a quelques jours
faut pas l'oublier la Corse aussi et à
force de de mettre une multitude de
sujets vous multipliez les sujets de
mécontentements et de division on peut
être d'accord sur l'IVG et pas être
d'accord sur l'IVG on peut être la Corse
mais pas l'environnement où je sais pas
quoi faut voyez il y a plein de formules
en réalité c'est des sujets sinon aucune
chance d'aboutir moi je pense que le
Président de la République fait de la
com
occupe l'espace aujourd'hui c'est les 65
ans de la quatrième de la 5e
25 gouvernements en 12 ans donc la
République des parties il y a déjà
beaucoup de complications vous savez
avec 10 groupes à l'Assemblée nationale
la démocratie vit mais parfois c'est
compliqué de la faire vivre donc non
plus plus sérieusement je crois qu'il y
a quand même un peu de comme de la part
du président de la République je
rappelle que il y a eu un fiasco en 2018
au moment des auditions de l'affaire
Benalla alors qu'on était en pleine
révision échec on met de côté on met au
frais et on n'a jamais pu ressortir le
produit là j'ai l'impression qu'en
faisant une étale hyper garnie
finalement on s'assure de pas avoir à
trancher parce que je pense qu'en
réalité la crainte aujourd'hui du
président de la République en allant
devant les électrices et les électeurs
par la voie du référendum c'est qu'il ne
répondent pas à la question de la
modification de la Constitution mais
qu'éventuellement ils en profite pour
sanctionner le gouvernement et le
président de la République
Antoine
il y a quand même un un sujet qui
pourrait réunir les parlementaires c'est
ce fameux référendum d'initiative
partagée toutes les oppositions l'ont
dit il a été conçu pour ne jamais être
déclenchée si on là on a souplissait les
critères pour que le citoyen participe à
la décision vous votez nous on est pour
on a même déposé une proposition de loi
sur le sujet pour abaisser le seuil à un
million donc nous là actuellement c'est
4,8 millions de personnes nous ont
proposé un million de personnes parce
que on estime que justement une
démocratie puissante et efficace c'est
une démocratie dans laquelle la
souveraineté du peuple et au centre de
la vie démocratique quand on limite la
souveraineté du peuple quand on donne
l'impression qu'on a peur des décisions
populaires c'est qu'il y a un problème
c'est que les gouvernances sont plus
vraiment les représentants du peuple et
qui sont les représentants d'autres
choses de quoi nous on va vous dire que
c'est les représentants d'intérêt
économiques qui sont pas vraiment les
mêmes intérêts économiques que ceux du
peuple donc nous on plaide pour une
souveraineté populaire maximum avec à la
fois ce référendum d'initiative partagée
avec un seuil mais aussi un référendum
d'initiative citoyenne donc là c'est les
citoyens carrément qui peuvent décider
de proposer une loi d'abroger une loi ou
même de changer leur constitution s'ils
le souhaitent d'une manière générale
nous les insoumis nous sommes des gens
qui n'avons pas peur d'aller vers les
urnes quel que soit le sujet et quel que
soit le type d'élection parce que on
estime que les moments de décision
populaire c'est des moments justement de
respiration démocratique et on a bien vu
d'ailleurs comment la présidentielle de
2022 alors qu'il y avait des mouvements
sociaux assez forts elle a servi un
petit peu à ça à la séance
d'aller à Versailles si c'était
uniquement là dessus
je pense pas que ce soit possible parce
que comme je pense je pense qu'on
pourrait bouger le niveau effectivement
des quatre millions
ça c'est 10% en réalité de désinscrits
sur la liste électorale c'est énorme
c'est inacceptation qu'il faut signer
sur un million un million cinq bon on
pourrait peut-être se mettre d'accord
là-dessus mais ça ne suffit pas est-ce
que par exemple on accepte que par le
voie de ce référendum partagé
d'initiatives partagées on modifie une
loi qui dont l'encre serait à peine
sèche voilà par exemple
une réforme quelle qu'elle soit je parle
pas de celle des retraites en
particulier
que vous alliez parler de celle-ci mais
on vient de voter une loi la
représentation nationale c'est-à-dire la
souveraineté c'est exprimée d'une façon
ou d'une autre en tout cas conformément
à la Constitution et le Conseil
constitutionnel la juger conforme et et
on peut pas se permettre six mois après
d'avoir un référendum qui
j'aimerais bien vous faire intervenir à
ce stade du débat le regard de Olivier
Viviane toute l'histoire politique de
notre pays elle est faite comme ça de de
concurrence entre la démocratie directe
la démocratie parlementaire
représentative versus populaire est-ce
qu'on est un moment comme ça où il faut
quand même peut-être accéder à davantage
de place aux citoyens
peut-être bon je me mêle très peu de ce
type de débat mais ce que je voulais
dire c'est que je suis toujours un petit
peu
affolé lorsque je vois des discussions
sur les textes constitutionnels qui est
quand même aussi une manie française
alors que des constitutions extrêmement
vagues je pense aux lois constitutionnel
de 1875 on relativement bien fonctionné
et donc l'idée que avec des révisions
constitutionnelles on va tout changer on
va enfin résoudre les problèmes qui se
posent au pays c'est quelque chose qui
me laisse éminemment sceptique
on ne peut pas changer la vie des gens
avec la Constitution mais en réalité ce
qui est intéressant dans ce discours
c'est peut-être qu'il n'y a pas
vous savez il y a des choses qui sont
pas dans la Constitution qui changent le
régime typiquement le mode de scrutin on
est l'un des seuls pays en Europe avec
la Grande-Bretagne qui avait un mode de
scrutin majoritaire on est pour on est
contre mais il y a un vrai débat
là-dessus du premier mandat la
proportionnelle
majorité notamment le modèle
Dada or en réalité ça passe par une
ordinaire le record pour voter de moins
ordinaire là vous pouvez donner le
dernier mot à l'Assemblée le record pour
voter une loi ordinaire sur la Troisième
République ces trois jours donc on
pourrait bouger ça on a beaucoup débattu
du cumul des mandats à l'opposé mais là
non plus ça y est pas et donc au bout du
compte on a des propositions qui vont
avoir beaucoup de mal à passer mais des
trucs qui pourraient être fait de
manière relativement simple et bien on
ne le propose pas ce qui a été évoqué
sur le référendum d'initiative partagé
il faut voir que Derrick véto c'est le
la modalité la plus répandue dans le
monde en Suisse en Italie en Italie vous
avez besoin de 500000 signatures et vous
faites un reg-veto sur une proposition
de loi ça va faire plaisir entre néo man
d'ailleurs la première version du riz
contre guillemets sous les fonctions
préalablement
par les citoyens là vous faites et puis
vous avez capital en plus une capacité
de mobilisation parce que vous opposez
une loi donc le fait que ça mais ça ça
me permet la démocratie représentative
ça existe un peu partout le fait qu'il
ferme la porte à ça montre que là-dessus
s'il y a réforme il y aura réformes donc
ce faisant on n'ira pas très loin
précisément c'est l'inverse parce que si
on prend le cas de la réforme des
retraites bon on va pas se voiler la
face la quasi intégralité du peuple
français était opposé à cette réforme
des retraites quand même sur 90 % des
actifs qui étaient contre cette réforme
de retraite le seul moyen de la faire
passer a été d'utiliser justement les
outils que nous on qualifie
d'autoritaire de la 5ème république avec
ce 49-3 pour le faire passer en force au
Parlement parce que y compris même au
Parlement alors qu'il y a plutôt une
majorité de droite on va dire libérale
qui était favorable au fait de faire
passer cette retraite à 64 voire à 65
ans pour certains et ben même là c'était
un peu chaud pour essayer de la faire
passer donc utilisation du 49-3 pour en
quelque sorte faire taire tout le monde
mais le peuple français lui dans cette
histoire là il a pas eu son mot à dire
il était pas d'accord et justement le
système majoritaire à deux tours fait
que quand on vote au deuxième tour on
élimine le candidat dont on veut pas on
choisit pas le candidat qu'on veut on
élimine le candidat dont on veut pas
donc dans l'élection professionnelle
aussi vous y êtes favorable
parce que entre la présidentielle et
l'élection législative on a perdu 20
points de participation 25 même pour une
participation et qui ne participe pas
aux élections législatives les classes
populaires qui sont justement celles et
ceux qui vont être les plus impactés par
la réforme des retraites et qui se
sentent le moins représentés par les
personnes qui sont dans l'assemblée donc
conclusion simplement pour finir sur ça
si on avait un référendum d'initiative
partagé ou citoyen sur cette question de
la réforme des retraites on sait
pertinemment quelle serait le résultat
donc question est-ce que l'article 3 de
la Constitution à respecter puisque il
dit que la souveraineté appartient au
peuple qu'il exerce par ses
représentants et par la voie du
référendum ni les représentants depuis
voter ni le peuple n'a pu voter alors
fais dû en même temps président est-ce
que vous serez l'avocat de la démocratie
représentative sur ce sujet du Rip moi
je défends effectivement pour une part
la démocratie représentative maintenant
vouloir opposer le peuple qui de toute
façon
Ellie s'est représentants au peuple qui
exerce sa souveraineté par la voie
référendaire ça n'a pas vraiment de sens
je crois qu'on a besoin des deux moi
j'ai aucune difficulté à ce que le
peuple puisse s'exprimer vous savez le
général de Gaulle le seuil est un
million pour le rip la réforme des
retraites
honnêtement c'est beaucoup trop pour
vous est-ce que c'est un million cinq
deux millions un million je j'en ai un
million je je ne sais pas
si si on prend d'autres comparaisons un
million pour être le chiffre qui
pourrait qui pourrait être celui-là un
million faut déjà mobiliser
effectivement c'est clair après si on a
une loi véto donc un référendum véto
c'est effectivement une formule beaucoup
plus simple on est pour on est contre et
là ça pourrait sur ce sujet là mobiliser
mais à ce moment-là il faut que les
règles du jeu soient claires et c'est
que dès le départ dès l'introduction
d'un sujet on choisisse l'une ou l'autre
voie parce que je ne connais pas la
question on va poser la légitimité des
parlementaires et des élus à celle du
peuple et on peut pas et on ne doit pas
pour des raisons de stabilité politique
du vivre ensemble on ne doit pas opposer
en permanence les uns et les autres il y
a des gens
et ça sera invivable et c'est la révolte
ça fait longtemps qu'on a pas eu de
référendum même moi je me suis de me
rappeler la dernière fois que j'avais
voté
ça fait 18 ans qu'on a pas voté sur un
référendum et un coup on a l'impression
que ça va tout sauver tous résoudre tous
nos problèmes moi je veux bien et je
pense que c'est ce qu'on a fait aussi
avec la convention citoyenne pour le
climat ou sur sur la fin de vie
consulter en ayant ce travail aussi
à fournique avait donné ses citoyens qui
étaient engagent mais apporte sa
contribution participe mais de décide
pas c'est la troisième sur les
référendum des années 70 à 90 il y a
aussi énormément d'abstention donc faut
pas imaginer et le dernier à Paris sur
les trottinettes le montre bien on voit
bien que l'abstention
nous empêchera aussi peut-être d'avoir
une vraie consultation Benjamin Morel le
mot de la fin il y a un rendez-vous de
Saint-Denis comme dit elle lisait le
format Saint-Denis avec l'ensemble des
chefs de parties qui se réunissent avec
le chef de l'État on va voir si ça dure
toute la nuit comme la première fois
qu'est-ce qu'on peut en attendre on
imagine que c'est de ça dont ils vont
discuter ce référence
discuter je pense que la France
insoumise sera d'accord pour un
référendum sur l'immigration et que lRN
seront d'accord pour l'ouverture du
référendum initiative citoyen dans toute
matière et avec un seuil de 500 000
soyons sérieux c'est-à-dire que là moi
ce qui me fait peur c'est qu'on va créer
des frustrations aujourd'hui vous avez
des Français qui attendent un référendum
un référendum sur l'immigration etc dire
on va faire des référendums alors que
Emmanuel Macron a évoqué le dernier
référendum national a été foulé au pied
en 2008 mais également de référendum
locaux pas de collectivité unique en
Corse il y a finalement il y en a eu
finalement une pas de collectivité
unique en Alsace il y en aura finalement
une Notre Dame des Landes ça ne devait
pas se faire ça se fait etc donc vous
voyez que derrière il y a beaucoup de
frustration aujourd'hui le sentiment que
la démocratie est écras
des référendum et qu'on ne va pas au
bout pour des raisons politiciennes
c'est très dangereux merci beaucoup on
va on va s'arrêter voilà sur cette
avertissement merci à vous d'avoir
participé à ce à ce débat en direct vous
restez avec moi Olivier viviorka dans
une dizaine de minutes les parties pris
de nous affranchis ils sont fin prêts ce
soir le philosophe Pierre-Henri tavoyau
qui va s'interroger sur la réforme en
cours des questions au Gouvernement
l'oeil sur le numérique de Delphine
Sabatier qui s'arrête sur le casse-tête
de l'interdiction de l'anonymat sur
Internet et puis d'un Bourbon Express
Stéphanie lespierre de quoi nous
parlez-vous d'une question qui ressurgit
régulièrement faut-il ou non voter les
propositions de loi du rassemblement
national à tout à l'heure les amis mais
d'abord on va se plonger dans ce livre
important histoire totale de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale chez Perrin 6 années de
travail Olivier viviorca et à l'arrivée
une synthèse à la fois magistrale et je
le disais accessible à tous qui abordent
tous les fronts du conflit les civils
comme les militaires bien sûr je n'en
dis pas plus regardez un avant-goût dans
ce sujet d'Elsa mundagaba et on en parle
tous les deux juste après
[Musique]
si on vous invite Olivier viviorca c'est
parce que vous livrez une synthèse
essentielle et inédite sur la Seconde
Guerre mondiale mille pages sur ces six
années qui bouleversèrent le monde sur
la France
vous êtes historien professeur à l'École
normale supérieure de Paris Saclay le
spécialiste de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale après histoire de la résistance
et du débarquement vous signez donc une
histoire totale de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale alors l'ambition d'une histoire
totale je m'excuse du caractère peut
être un peu prétentieux du titre mais
l'histoire totale cela veut dire que ce
n'est pas simplement une histoire
militaire et donc lorsqu'on parle de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale on pense
immédiatement au bataille à stalingrada
course à Midway à Pearl Harbor mais ces
batailles elles s'insèrent dans un
contexte elle s'insère dans un contexte
géopolitique les batailles il faut
également des hommes il faut aussi du
matériel il faut donc les produire ce
que je veux dire en d'autres termes
c'est qu'il faut resituer cette histoire
militaire dans un contexte général et
donc de ce conflit vous en déclinez tous
les aspects militaires évidemment un
million de soldats 170 000 véhicules les
charssaut mais aussi civils
des gens moyens qui travaillent aux
champs à l'usine au bureau sans fui ta
famille et raciale dans votre livre vous
évoquez bien sûr la Shoah mais avec une
place à part évidemment elle n'aurait
pas eu lieu sans la guerre mais elle
répond à une logique presque
indépendante Olivier viviorka vous nous
amener sur tous les fronts européens
soviétiques asiatique et vous vous
interrogez sur les dilemmes cruciaux
devant lesquels cette guerre a placé
tous les individus vous parlez d'abîmes
d'horreur contre sommet de grandeur
[Musique]
alors une guerre mondiale totale mais
aussi morale
ben voilà cette question qui vous est
soumise est-ce que finalement les
populations qui ont vécu cette seconde
guerre mondiale ont vécu une guerre avec
des questions éthiques pour la première
fois salon contre héros ou pas oui vous
avez entièrement raison de poser la
question en ces termes même si
l'historien ne va pas faire un traité de
morale ou d'éthique à partir de ce livre
l'important c'est de comprendre mais les
individus je crois ont été saisis par
des dilemmes moraux qui ne se posaient
pas me semble-t-il lors de la première
guerre mondiale pendant la Première
Guerre mondiale si vous voulez voilà le
poilu va combattre éventuellement vous
avez effectivement des mutineries dont
on sait qu'elles ne sont pas une preuve
de pacifisme mais une preuve de
lassitude mais l'éventail des choix
moraux et des dilemmes et relativement
limités tel n'est pas le cas pour la
seconde guerre mondiale parce que ce qui
se produit je crois c'est que cette
guerre mondiale est une guerre mais dans
le même temps il faut bien se rappeler
que tout un ensemble de pays sortent de
la guerre au sens opération militaire
c'est le cas de la France entre juin
1940 néanmoins 1944 hormis la Corse on
ne se bat pas donc cela veut dire que
les pays sont exposés à d'autres
logiques et c'est logique ce sont les
logiques de l'occupation et les logiques
également
donc logique de l'occupation et
logique de régime autoritaire ou
totalitaire qui impose leurs lois bien
sûr mais donc ces questions de du prix
de la liberté se pose d'autant plus avec
avec cette question voilà de l'occupant
et de la collaboration on va reprendre
du début sur les termes cette guerre
est-elle véritablement mondiale ça n'est
pas si évident à vous lire en tout cas à
l'époque ça n'est pas le cas pour tout
le monde non parce que on parle de
Seconde Guerre mondiale et j'ai un petit
peu voulu questionner ce que l'on
entendait par là alors si on veut dire
que oui la guerre mondiale elle est
mondiale parce que l'on se bat sur les
quatre continents sur quatre continents
sur 5 oui oui elle est mondiale dans le
même temps si vous voulez est-ce qu'elle
est mondiale dans la tête des gens dans
la tête des combattants voir dans la
tête les dirigeants on constate non on
constate que pour Hitler qui affirme le
caractère mondial de la guerre la guerre
est d'abord une aventure européenne peut
être africaine en aucun cas asiatique
vous n'avez aucune coopération
stratégique entre le Japon et
l'Allemagne lorsque l'on regarde
également le Royaume-Uni est-ce que
c'est une guerre mondiale oui bien sûr
l'Empire britannique est malmené la
Malaisie est occupée la Birmanie et
conquise par les Japonais mais dans le
même temps les britannique ne consacrent
jamais plus de 10% de leur effort de
guerre à conduire des opérations en Asie
ce qui veut dire que pour la
Grande-Bretagne la guerre elle est
d'abord et avant tout européenne
africaine et moyen-orientales elle n'est
pas mondiale de Gaulle par les mêmes de
la guerre de 30 ans et de Gaulle pour
des raisons assez
mystérieuse puisque vous savez que le
l'appel du 18 juin et prophétique il est
visionnaire celle guerre mondiale ça
devienne guerre mondiale mais lorsqu'il
en parle en public après il affirme que
s'il s'agit d'une guerre de 30 ans et je
pense que bien entendu la volonté du
général de Gaulle est une volonté
rassemblement et qu'il cherche à
déshydroliser le conflit en leur amenant
une opposition traditionnelle entre la
France et l'Allemagne sur les dates là
aussi c'était intéressant tout le monde
connaissait date par cœur on les apprend
à l'école 39 45 là encore les historiens
ne sont pas tous d'accord sur ni sur le
début ni sur la fin non alors vous avez
si vous voulez certains historiens qui
je le crains par posture affirme que la
guerre que nous nous estimons commencé
en 1939 en fait commence en 1937 voire
en 1931 date à laquelle le Japon
commence à grignoter puis à attaquer la
Chine bon pourquoi pas mais si l'on
prend le terme de guerre mondiale au
pied de la lettre cette guerre ne
commence ni entre un ni en 37 ni en 39
elle commence véritablement en 41
les Américains sont frappés à Pearl
Harbor dans les îles Hawaï par le Japon
en rétorsion les Allemands et les
Italiens déclarent la guerre aux
États-Unis et il faut rappeler enfin que
l'Union soviétique est Atta par la
Wehrmacht le 22 juin 1941 donc si l'on
veut vraiment parler de guerre mondiale
effectivement on doit parler de 1941
comme date de début alors on va revenir
sur ce que vous appelez les mythes de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale et ces mythes on
l'a dans dure il persiste encore
aujourd'hui et parfois ils sont
fabriqués par la propagande pas
forcément des vaincu ça peut être des
vainqueurs mais ça peut être aussi celle
des vaincu l'opération Barbarossa alors
expliquez-nous c'est la grande grande
opération militaire quand Hitler
retourne les armes contre les
Soviétiques en 1941 on raconte ça un peu
comme comme à l'époque de Napoléon c'est
le froid de l'hiver qui a contribué à la
défaite des Allemands oui alors les
généraux allemands expliquent que si la
guerre a été perdue c'est en raison de
l'hiver d'une part et en raison d'autre
part des interventions incessantes
d'Adolf Hitler qui se mélange de tout
empêche les professionnels de faire leur
travail et cette vision a été
popularisée par les chefs allemands
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale non
seulement dans leur mémoire mais
également dans le travail dirait-on
aujourd'hui de consultant qu'ils avaient
à l'égard des Américains or ce que l'on
constate c'est que cette opération
Barbarossa a été préparée en dépit du
bon sens alors mythe que nous avons nous
culturellement on voit les allemands
comme très organisés très discipliné
autant vous dire que dans l'armée
allemande la logistique c'est le cadet
des soucis des des chefs allemands donc
ils sont partis dans cette opération
absolument démesurée avec insuffisamment
d'essence un pas de moyen de transport
il tape sur le réseau ferré soviétique
qui est à voie unique étable sur le
réseau routier qui est à l'habiteux et
donc vous avez cette image d'allemand
soi-disant regardant à la jumelle les
coupoles du Kremlin c'est un mythe car
contreensif de joue coffre le 5 décembre
ou pas contrefensive de Joukov le 5
décembre et bien il n'avait tout
simplement plus assez d'essence pour
avancer c'était perdu d'avance côté
allemand romelle un général allemand à
nouveau le grand tacticien militaire de
du Nord là encore pour lui l'intendance
doit suivre et il va le payer et on a
gardé pourtant l'idée d'un grand chef
militaire oui parce que d'une part il y
a le docteur gobels qui a martelé par sa
propagande que Romain est un grand chef
les Britanniques eux-mêmes relaient
cette propagande en disant nous avons
très peur de remettre et puis il y a
quand même le suicide de romaine en 1944
parce qu'il est plus ou moins soupçonné
d'avoir trempé contre l'attente dans
l'attentat contre Adolf Hitler du 20
juillet 1944 donc il se suicide donc
c'est au fond un peu aussi un général
propre Romel lorsque l'on regarde de
plus près ce n'est certainement pas le
nazi sanguinaire ceci dit c'est un nazi
quand même au départ et il faut bien
souligner qu'il y a eu des exactions
comme mise en Afrique du Nord et que
pour reprendre des titres de mémoire de
Romel posthume la guerre sans haine ça
peut être été une guerre sans haine mais
ça n'a pas été une guerre sans barbarie
le débarquement là aussi vous balayez
quelques quelques légendes
en fait certes victoires immédiate mais
beaucoup plus difficile après et on a
gardé que effectivement ces images du
soldat Ryan du film de Spielberg en tête
oui tout à fait le débarquement en
lui-même ce que les stratèges appellent
le touchdown c'est à dire le 6 juin 1944
le 6 juin 1944 les 5 plages du
débarquement sont prises au prix en gros
de 10000 pertes mais en général de la
guerre de 14 aurait rêvé d'obtenir ces
résultats avec aussi peu de pertes je le
répète et des résultats aussi
magnifiques et cela bien évidemment nous
ne le voyons pas pourquoi parce que nous
nous projetons aussi dans la peau de ces
soldats qui débarquent sous la mitraille
et qui pour la première vague pour la
première vague sont effectivement
décimés vous avez en gros 40% de perte
mais en fait le débarquement en lui-même
c'est très bien passé ce qui est
abominable c'est ce qui va suivre
campagne de Normandie le bocage et là
les pertes sont très élevées le moral
chute et vous avez une une épidémie de
maladies psychiatrique qui se répand
c'est à dire que vous avez en gros un
soldat sur deux un soldat sur 3 malade
qui est en fait victime de ces nerfs il
est en incapacité de combattre en raison
précisément de ce qu'on aurait appelé le
shell shock pendant la Première Guerre
mondiale on va regarder le front
asiatique et là on apprend énormément de
choses déjà Hiroshima Nagasaki pour
franchement là je pense
quasi-totalité des personnes sur cette
planète pense que c'est ce sont ces deux
bombes qui ont permis au Japon de
capituler et vous dites ça n'est pas ça
alors c'est plus compliqué que ça parce
que vous avez la bombe atomique qui est
largué la première bombe atomique sur
orchimal le 6 août mais l'empereur
attend le 15 août pour annoncer qu'il va
capituler et en fait dans cette
capitulation japonaise vous avez un
élément qui est déterminant qui est
l'offensive soviétique d'une voûte
Staline va décider d'attaquer en Extrême
Orient or non seulement il attaque en
Extrême-Orient mais il avance très vite
beaucoup plus vite que ce que les
Japonais croyaient et donc les Japonais
sont confrontés à un dilemme cornélien
est-ce qu'il vaut mieux être sous
occupations américaines ou s'occupations
soviétiques et le choix est vite fait
donc la capitulation du Japon s'explique
d'abord et avant tout me semble-t-il par
le Francis soviétique plus que par les
mondes atomiques ceci dit si nous nous
pensons que c'est en raison des bons
atomiques c'est parce que vous avez eu
ce qu'on appellerait aujourd'hui un
storytelling un récit américain et
japonais les Américains qui lisent on a
emporté la décision ce qui permet
d'éviter que les Soviétiques réclament
des droits sur le Japon et l'empereur
qui dit regardez comme je suis humain
nous avons été frappé par la coupe au
calyps certains jusqu'au-boutistes
voulaient vraiment se battre jusqu'à la
dernière cartouche mais moi empereur
héroïto j'ai consenti à la paix sur la
Shoah et la destruction des Juifs la
destruction massives des Juifs d'Europe
vous citez primolée vit dans Si c'est un
homme à Auschwitz n'a rien à voir avec
la guerre elle ne constitue pas une
étape elle n'en est pas une forme
outrancière il une particularité totale
de la Shoah dans le conflit est-ce que
c'est une histoire totalement parallèle
ou pas non bien entendu ce n'est pas une
histoire totalement parallèle ce que je
veux dire c'est que sans la guerre il
n'y aurait pas eu de Shoah sans la
guerre également Hitler n'aurait pas
capturé des millions de Juifs pour qui
l'extermination a représenté enfin pour
Adolf Hitler à l'extermination
représentait une solution logique pour
gérer cette cette masse humaine mais
dans le même temps si vous le voulez on
a en fait ce que une historienne qui
s'appelle Annick Riel appelait une
guerre privée contre les Juifs qui se
déroule en quelque sorte en parallèle
donc vous avez des connexions par
exemple la Wehrmacht les forces
régulières qui ont affirmé après la
guerre que les massacres c'était juste
les SS e étaient propres des
professionnels non l’avait remarque
trempe dans ses crimes de masse à l'est
donc ici vous avez des connexions vous
avez également des connexions avec tout
ce qui concerne par exemple le trafic
ferroviaire mais si je connection il ne
faut pas non plus les surestimer
pourquoi vous avez tant de déporter qui
meurent sur dans les trains qui les qui
les conduisent dans les centres de mise
à mort c'est parce que les convois
militaires sont toujours prioritaires
donc on va les garer de côté en
attendant que les convois militaire
passe dans cette mesure si vous voulez
on a une histoire de la Shoah qui n'est
pas une histoire très fortement
connectée à l'histoire de la de la
guerre vous exactement aux grandes
opérations même si bien entendu il y a
des passerelles et des liens je voulais
vous parler quand même des guerres
d'aujourd'hui vous faites d'ailleurs des
parallèles dans le livre est-ce que on
pense à l'esprit de munique 1938 ce qui
a permis à éclair de récupérer une
partie de la Tchécoslovaquie les Sudètes
avec l'accord de la France de l'Italie
et du Royaume-Uni est-ce que nos
dirigeons aujourd'hui face à la gare du
crâne on comprit dans cette clairvoyance
de ne pas retomber dans ça ou pas non je
ne le crois pas vous savez que les
historiens sont très sévères à l'égard
d'Aladin et de Chamberlain qui partent à
Munich et qui acceptent au fond que la
Tchécoslovaquie soit dépecée mais je
pense que les historiens de demain
seront très sévères avec les dirigeants
qui ont font laissé Vladimir Poutine
annexer la Crimée au fond on a le même
processus qui tient me semble-t-il au
même cause c'est-à-dire que la
rationalité de l'adversaire Vladimir
Poutine en l'occurrence et bien elle est
très difficile à percer les dirigeants
français et britanniques pensaient que
au fond Hitler était un nouveau Bismarck
un nouveau Guillaume 2 et j'imagine que
les dirigeants français ont imaginé que
Poutine était un nouveau brégnès or mon
corps un problème d'aveuglement et de et
de lucidité c'est absolument passionnant
vous serez aux rencontres de l'histoire
à Blois LCP et partenaire je profite
pour montrer l'affiche les vivants et
les morts ce sont évidemment des
ateliers des rencontres des dédicaces et
de votre livre en particulier Olivier
viviorka si vous avez la chance de vous
rendre à Blois n'hésitez pas ça commence
aujourd'hui ça se termine dimanche
prochain une histoire totale de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale vous l'avez
compris c'est un livre important c'est
un livre accessible et c'est absolument
passionnant sur la vérité en histoire
contre au fond les mythes et légendes
fabriqués des deux côtés vous restez
avec moi Olivier Cassez leur
d'accueillir nos parties pris nos
affranchis ils vont vous faire réagir on
les accueille tout de suite bienvenue à
vous les chroniqueurs ce soir
Pierre-Henri tavoyau du collège de
philosophie installez-vous Delphine
Sabatier de Bismarck qui va nous parler
de l'anonymat sur Internet mais on
commence comme chaque soir par Bourbon
Express l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
c'est vous qui nous la racontez
Stéphanie des pierres bonsoir à vous
bonsoir alors cette histoire du jour
alors cette histoire du jour je vous
parle d'une histoire ou plutôt d'une
question qui se répète depuis l'entrée
de 88 députés d'extrême droite à
l'Assemblée nationale l'année dernière
faut-il ou non voter avec le
rassemblement national on en a encore eu
une illustration aujourd'hui alors que
les propositions de loi du rassemblement
national étaient discutée en commission
alors dans le camp présidentiel pas
question de voter avec eux le chef des
députés a rappelé la ligne
nous la digue tient parfaitement ça me
clair avec nos idées nous ne voterons
pas de texte du rassemblement national
et
battu faisait de mieux accompagner les
femmes atteintes d'endométriose en 2022
le gouvernement avait annoncé une
stratégie nationale de lutte contre
cette maladie sans changement concret
pour le moment c'est aussi un combat de
la gauche et bien le rassemblement
national avait sciemment choisi ce thème
pour pousser les autres parties à voter
avec lui infinie le camp présidentiel à
la rejeté tous les articles un parole la
nupette s'est abstenue la proposition
loi a donc été rejetée et à la sortie
sans surprise le RN dénonce le
sectarisme des autres groupes je note
que un certain nombre de groupes de
l'Assemblée nationale pensent
systématiquement à leur intérêt
politicien et pas à l'intérêt supérieur
des Français et en l'occurrence des
Françaises
la gauche elle accuse le rassemblement
national de plagiat car l'insoumise
Clémentine autant a déjà fait adopter en
2022 par l'Assemblée nationale une
partie de ces propositions sur
l'endométriose
comment vous allez expliquer aux femmes
qui souffrent d'endométriose que vous
n'avez pas voté cette proposition de loi
on va juste leur expliquer que cette
proposition là ne fait pas avancer d'un
iota par rapport à un au travail qui a
déjà été fait par le mental par les
parlementaires et deux qui a déjà été
fait par le gouvernement franchement
c'est trop facile d'arriver en bout de
course et de dire ah bah regardez c'est
nous qui faisons bouger les choses sur
ce sujet de santé publique crucial mais
pour lequel le RN est dans une pure
stratégie opportuniste une stratégie du
coucou voilà ils viennent se mettre dans
le Nick a été travaillé par les autres
c'est une proposition loi qui est très
mal fagotée c'est pas au bon endroit
dans le code de la santé publique donc
elle n'est pas très opérante et surtout
chacun et chacune peut mesurer
l'opération politicienne qu'il y a là
derrière puisque le rassemblement
national est très concrètement l'ennemi
de l'émancipation des femmes donc c'est
la politique que dit du cordon sanitaire
face à l'extrême droite qui qui s'est
opérée dans l'hémicycle ça veut dire que
cette proposition n'est soutenue par
personne pour les femmes Myriam par les
républicains ils étaient les seuls à
proposer des amendements pour améliorer
le texte et ils ont voté le principal
article la députée Isabelle Valentin
explique que ça peut permettre de faire
avancer les choses et assume de voter
avec le RN ça me dérangera pas de voter
avec eux du moment où on fait avancer
une cause et une cause qui est qui doit
être défendu qui est une cause nationale
10% des femmes en l'âge de procréer
c'est énorme en plus les femmes qui ont
de l'endométriose je veux dire elles
sont quand même dans une souffrance
c'est des maladies qui sont invalidantes
donc oui il faut faire avancer si c'est
le moyen de faire avancer moi ça me
dérange pas alors vis-à-vis des
républicains le rassemblement national
avait aussi été habile puisqu'il a
repris une proposition phare de la
droite souvent défendue par eriki la
suspension des allocations familiales
aux parents de délinquants là encore les
LR ne pouvait que soutenir finalement
sur la journée d'aujourd'hui les
républicains ont soutenu 5 des six
textes du rassemblement national ils
n'ont donc plus d'état d'âme à
s'associer à la crème droite le patron
des républicains Olivier Marleix là
d'ailleurs acté hier il ne veut plus de
cordon sanitaires mais il ne l'avait
jamais dit aussi clairement on a une
seule ligne de conduite c'est voter ce
qui nous paraît
utile pour les Français on ne doit pas
contre nos idées nous arrivent aussi de
voter des textes proposées par Emmanuel
Macron donc voilà enfin vu que ça vienne
on va tu vois
des républicains aucune proposition de
loi n'a été adoptée le débat recommence
la semaine prochaine dans l'hémicycle on
suivra ça de près sur LCP bien sûr
Pierre-Henri tavoyau vous avez un sujet
très chienne parlementaire ce sont les
questions au Gouvernement ça ne vous a
pas échappé la présidente de l'Assemblée
propose de les de les réformer vous avez
des propositions à lui faire oui alors
d'abord c'est un sujet qui est pas
anecdotique parce que c'est vrai on
l'oublie parfois la démocratie c'est pas
simplement eu un jeu de loi ou de
succession de de décision c'est aussi
une scène c'est aussi un spectacle alors
en son temps au Platon avait parlé de la
tearocratie alors évidemment c'était
plutôt critique c'était pour dénoncer la
démagogie régnait sur la place publique
mais Platon n’étaient pas démocrate je
le rappelle Rousseau qu'il était
davantage lui était aussi au style au
théâtre il considérait que le théâtre
c'était la métaphore de l'ancien régime
il y avait les nobles qui jouaient puis
le peuple qui était spectateur qui ne
faisait rien il était favorable à la
fête qui deviendra la fête
révolutionnaire mais Rousseau et
démocrate mais il est démocrate direct
non représentatif or la démocratie la
nôtre c'est une démocratie
représentative et il y a aussi des
représentations théâtrales et ça c'est
important alors les propositions de
notre président de l'Assemblée nationale
bon sont pas révolutionnaires sur ce
sujet c'est des questions plus courtes
une augmentation du débat de temps
d'espace chez de manière un peu
différente c'est pas révolutionnaire
alors on pourrait s'inspirer de d'autres
modèles alors voilà moi proposition
c'est de parler du modèle anglais que je
trouve extrêmement séduisant parce que
ce modèle anglais est le suivant c'est
que c'est le premier ministre qui est
tout seul devant l'Assemblée et
notamment